with a sudden drop in temperature
experts say you're more likely to catch
a cold during chillier weather but not
for the reasons you may think it's gonna
be a pretty abrupt change Stan sizzic is
a meteorologist at the National Weather
Service Las Vegas we're at a high
temperature of 79 yesterday we'll be in
the 60s today but looks like we'll only
be in the 50s for tomorrow it's abrupt
it's not too unusual for this time of
year with a sneak peek of winter around
the corner some people may think the
colder weather makes you sick Dr
Christopher Choi says this is a myth
cold weather does not cause cold however
the viruses tend to thrive better in the
cold weather
and because of that we can actually
catch the viral infection a little more
readily in the Colder Weather he says
with more people opting to stay inside
this also increases the risk for
infections as viruses are easily spread
through human contact too so when the
temperature drops quickly then the body
hasn't uh adjusted to it now there are
some thoughts that our immune system may
not work as well when the temperature
drops so there are certain things we can
do this includes boosting your vitamin C
and D levels especially when there's
less sunlight during the winter staying
hydrated and getting the proper amount
of sleep to keep your immune system
healthy to fight off infections I think
we can expect a little a little worse a
flu season we've already seen flu cases
in Vegas as early as back in even July
or August we sell like first case right
now in my practice there is a huge
uptick in people with a viral illnesses
Dr Choi says good hygiene such as
washing your hands and covering your
mouth and nose when you sneeze or are
good preventative measures Mary Jane
beliesza 8 News Now